bei der flugkatastrophe im juli 2021
haben allein im aartal 134 menschen ihr
leben verloren eine besondere tragödie
ereignete sich in einer einrichtung der
lebenshilfe für menschen mit behinderung
in sinzig
zwölf menschen sind dort im erdgeschoss
des hauses ertrunken
die gruppe im erdgeschoss des
haupthauses wurde durch das mit
erheblicher wucht durch das gebäude
strömende wasser getötet zumindest für
diese personen ist jedenfalls anzunehmen
dass sie bei einer früheren deutlicheren
warnung hätten gerettet werden
warum gehörte ausgerechnet gruppe der
menschen mit behinderung zu den
todesopfern in sinzig wie sicher sind
geistig und körperlich beeinträchtigte
menschen eigentlich in extremsituationen
[Musik]
der fall in sinzig ist nur ein beispiel
für ein weltweites problem in japan
flora und in kalifornien kam es zu
ähnlichen tragödien
2004 bei einem taifun in japan waren
mehr als 60 prozent der opfer über 65
und oder pflegebedürftig 2017 starben in
florida in folge von harry kennt birma
12 seniorinnen in einem altersheim die
menschen erstickten wegen der extrem
hohen temperaturen die typischerweise
nach einem tropensturm auftreten schuld
war auch die ausgefallene klimaanlage in
dem heim
2018 beim campfire waldbrand war der
großteil der über 80 todesopfer
seniorinnen und oder menschen mit
behinderung
die un weist immer wieder darauf hin
dass polen gruppen besonders
schutzbedürftig sind gerade in solchen
situationen
2006 die vereinten nationen
verabschieden die
behindertenrechtskonvention
dem übereinkommen über die rechte von
menschen mit behinderungen werden sie
nicht mehr als krank sondern als
vollständig gleichberechtigte menschen
bezeichnet andreas schäfer vom
karlsruher institut für technologie
untersucht den einfluss von
naturkatastrophen auf unsere
gesellschaft den opferzahlen von
naturkatastrophen kann man unter seit
jahrzehnten feststellen dass für ältere
dass frauen jüngere und auch menschen
gibt weder affen einschränkung
überproportional todesopfern sind ist
immer so sie sehen am letzten die
letzten in der hackordnung in
anführungsstrichen das klingt jetzt sehr
drastisch aber im grunde versucht man
erst mal grundlegend die bevölkerung von
naturkatastrophen zu schützen
die am einfachsten zu schützen sind und
arbeitet sich dann entsprechenden
stufenweise nach oben der fall des
lebenshilfe haus in sinzig zeigt an
vielen stellen was generell beim schutz
von variablen gruppen schief läuft
der erste wichtige punkt sind die
warenketten wenn sie versagen können
evakuierungen scheitern wie im fall der
flut im lebenshilfe haus in dem sie
aktuell untersucht die
staatsanwaltschaft ob die menschen
hätten gerettet werden können um den
verlauf der flutkatastrophe zu verstehen
starten wir am 14 juli 2021 am tag der
flug selbst gab das landesumweltamt
rheinland pfalz um 11 17 die
zweithöchste warnstufe für das
einzugsgebiet an der aa aus die bewohner
innen des art hals wurde vor einer krohn
hochwassergefährdung gewarnt die
offiziellen richtlinien des landes
rheinland-pfalz schreiben vor dass ab
warnstufe 4 3 die unterstützung
hilfsbedürftiger personen bei der
räumung von gefährdeten wohnungen
erfolgen muss die kreisverwaltung die in
solchen situationen für die evakuierung
von pflegeheim zuständig ist warnte um
14 uhr 34 vor örtlichen überschwemmungen
erst um 23 uhr 9 reagiert der krisenstab
und ruft den katastrophenfall aus jetzt
werden die bereiche 50 metern links und
50 meter rechts der geräumt das
lebenshilfe haus befindet sich aber 250
meter von der ahr entfernt und wurde
somit nicht geräumt was ist in den
folgenden stunden im haus der
lebenshilfe passiert warum konnten die
menschen nicht gerettet werden obwohl
das wasser das haus erst und 32
erreichte diesen fragen widmen wir uns
in einer doku zu sehen in der zdf
mediathek kurz vor 3 führten wir denn da
einstimmen hilfe hilfe
der nacht das leben gerettet und science
und da kann man den beim besten willen
was wir vorher sollte man machen wenn du
machst du denn dafür verantwortlich dass
das wasser kommt das konnte keiner
aufhalten 6 - zu viele leute sterben
müssen schaut unbedingt unsere doko in
der mediathek dahin findet ihr hier über
die infobox und in der video
beschreibung
hydrologin hannah clark von der
university of reading ist einer der
absoluten flut expertin in europa sie
hat das europäische hochwasser waren
system mitentwickelt
die gerade schon erwähnt befindet sich
das haus der lebenshilfe circa 250 meter
von der ahr entfernt warum wird eine
solche einrichtung überhaupt so nah am
wasser gebaut
in deutschland berechnung behörden wie
hoch das risiko für überschwemmung in
einem bestimmten gebiet ist je nachdem
wie hoch das risiko ist müssen besondere
schutzmaßnahmen getroffen werden oder
dass da von dem jeweiligen gebiet gar
nicht erst gebaut werden
das lebenshilfe hause liegt innerhalb
eines nachrichtlich angezeigten
überschwemmungsgebietes klingt sperrig
und bedeutet dass bei einem
extremhochwasser diese gebiete
überschwemmt werden können rein
rechtlich darf dort aber gebaut werden
zurück zum lebenshilfe haus in der flut
nacht im hauptgebäude in sinzig waren 30
menschen untergebracht acht weitere in
diesem nebenhaus alles menschen mit
behinderung in der flut nacht war nur
ein betreuer für diese insgesamt 38
personen zuständig bestätigt uns die
lebenshilfe wir schauen uns jetzt mal an
wie der pflegeschlüssel für nachtwachen
ist lediglich in bayern
baden-württemberg bremen und hessen gibt
es feste personalschlüssel für
nachtwachen in rheinland pfalz gibt es
keine konkrete regelung laut dem
vorstand der lebenshilfe wurde 2015
einen antrag auf finanzierung einer
zweiten stelle bei einer nachtwache
abgelehnt johannes schweitzer ist
geschäftsführer der
landesarbeitsgemeinschaft selbsthilfe
für menschen mit behinderung und
chronischer erkrankung rheinland pfalz
also die personalschlüssel
nachtwachen oder nach diensten in der im
fall 136 sind durchaus üblich und
natürlich dass es so in allen
einrichtungen muss über nacht versorgung
gibt es ist eher so dass nachts weniger
personal eingesetzt wird und das ist
natürlich grundsätzlich nicht
zufriedenstellen kann eine einzelne
person denn im extremfall 36 menschen
evakuieren kommt natürlich immer darauf
an was für einen personenkreis es sich
handelt aber wenn man sich nur
vorstellen sie haben mehrere menschen
die unterstützung bei der mobilität
haben oder bettlägerig sind dann ist
davon auszugehen dass auch drei personen
wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichen werden
dabei waren es in der flut nicht 36
sondern sogar 38 menschen mit
behinderung für die nur ein betreuer
zuständig war während die lebenshilfe
bestätigt es kann nicht von einer person
erwartet werden so viele menschen unter
zeitdruck zu evakuieren
wir halten also fest die empfindlichsten
unserer gesellschaft sind immer noch
nicht ausreichend geschützt und das
liegt vor allem daran dass es in unserer
gesellschaft keine ausreichende
sensibilisierung für die belange und
bedürfnisse von menschen mit
behinderungen gibt ohne diese
sensibilisierung kann es auch zukünftig
zu tragödien wie im aartal kommen wenn
ihr euch jetzt fragt was passiert wenn
ein kollektives versagen auf schlechtes
timing trifft wenn politik und behörden
die vorstellungskraft für eine
herannahen der katastrophe fehlt dann
schaut unbedingt unsere doku in der
mediathek